hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the final round on the
saint louis rapid event
uh so the the third day of rapid it's
alexander grisha vs magnus carlsen
and it's uh like i said it's quite the
game but it's also a very important game
for the standings of the tournament so
uh without further ado let's check it
out as
sasha has the white pieces and he opens
with e4
magnus of course goes for his sicilian
with c5 knight f3
d6 and now d4 uh striking in the center
so uh very
normal stuff captures captures and the
knight to f6 we have knight to c3
and here magnus goes for g6 he goes
immediately
for the dragon variation of the sicilian
uh which is uh
well at some point it uh you know fell
out of fashion because the
black uh black player thought that it's
gonna be too easy for white to attack
but now it's slowly coming back
uh with players uh of uh you know uh
very very very great skills such as
magnus also danny luba very very big fan
of the dragon
are playing it uh and and of course a
lot of other people
so let's see how sasha deals with it and
uh is he able to tame
the dragon we have bishop to e3 uh
preparing the yugoslav attack we have
bishop to g7
preparing the castle and f3 now the
yugoslav attack is on the board
uh white is ready for black the castle
and then of course uh white monster
uh bust open black's king side with a6
magnus
will now prepare to push on the queen
side and queen to d2
of course at some point you want to have
the option of trading off the dark
square bishop as this is black's
strongest piece and now the immediate h5
preventing any sudden pushes on the king
side so if
uh sasha wants to push he's definitely
going to have to prepare it
uh rather than just uh starting with h4g
for like
like you would enjoy bishop to c4
uh developing the bishop to this very
nice diagonal
and knight beat to d7 preparing to shift
the knight over to c5 with bishop back
to b3
and knight to c5 now putting pressure on
the bishop but also
on the center here we have side castle
and here uh there is a game where bishop
to d7 was played but b5 uh
immediately in this position is a new
move so already as of move 11 we have a
completely new game and now magnus wants
to play bishop b7 rook c8 b4 and and
continue attacking here
uh so here we have king to b1 a nice
prophylactic move by
grishok and bishop to b7 so these are
normal developing moves uh for the night
or
uh sorry for for a lot of sicilians
including
uh uh the knight of s this is the dragon
uh we have a3 and now knight captures on
b3
now getting rid of this bishop uh it's a
very strong bishop controlling this
diagonal so you might as well
get rid of it mess up a white spawn
structure here and bring your rook to
the c
file so captures captures and now rook
the c8
uh here uh we have knights to c2 uh
grisha has
complete control of the d5 square here
but he wants to
impr even uh improve his control so he
wants to bring the knight to c2 to b4
and then
bring this knight over to d5 and then
it's going to be an amazing piece there
so knight back to c2 uh we have queen to
c7
and now bishop to d4 uh just uh
uh countering this uh this bishop here
on g7
we have castles finally by magnus and
now queen back to f2 and here you have
to be
somewhat careful for example if rook d8
just bishop b6 wins the exchange
so you have to uh you know be very
careful on what you do here and here
magnus goes for uh
pawn to e5 now this forces uh grisha to
uh to state what he his plans are with
with the
dark square bishop however uh you no
longer have the option of playing e6
since this pawn is already on e5 and you
don't have a c
pawn so the d5 square is now even weaker
and the d6 point will be uh
will be a great weakness in the position
so bishop to b6 uh which tempo
as it attacks the queen queen d7 and
only now knight to b4 and now
the knight is coming to d5 uh and here
well
uh you could go for something like queen
e6 go after the b3 pawn
uh magnus goes for rook captures on c3
and this is a
usually a a signature night or move but
you can
as you can see play play it in a lot of
lines of the sicilian so rook captures
on c3
giving up the exchange here at uh
further weaken
uh uh grisham's queen side and now queen
to e6 going after the pawn here
so grishok defends it king to b2 and now
comes
rook to c8 by magnus and now he has a
lot of pressure here
you could even have some ideas of maybe
capturing here
just to open up this uh diagonal of the
dark square bishop for example
if you made a if you made a slow move
here let's say you play h3 then ids like
bishop captures on e4 come to mind
f captures knight captures with an
attack on the bishop and on the pawn
here
you will not be able to defend the next
move you're going to capture here you're
going to move this pawn you're going to
open up
this diagonal and it's going to be a
much better game for black uh however
after this rook the c8 move there is
one move that really allows greyshook to
uh to make something more of the
position uh but it's not an easy move to
find it's an incredibly strong defensive
and attacking move so uh feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this only move that uh you know can
can uh get uh some advantage in this
position over magnus well i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
this
incredibly difficult move to find uh and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's
bishop to a5 and bishop to a5 serves as
both an attacking move and as a
defensive move uh because
how do you find such a move well your
queen is currently doing nothing and you
would very much enjoy if your queen did
something it is the
the most important the strongest piece
uh in chess
uh so here bishop the a5 opens up this
diagonal and queen is coming to
the a7 and this will be a big problem
because it's going to be
hard to keep an eye on d6 which is a
huge weakness you are never playing d5
and also if the queen comes here you
will have pressure on the a6 pawn so
uh we we might call this the principle
of two weaknesses not not quite but
uh let's say that this is that we we
could um
uh characterize it as such so here
magnus has to
decide how to go about this and he could
try uh
bishop captures an e4 here however here
queen to b6 is just too strong you're
you're just going after the pawn you're
going after this pawn and you are
threatening to
to win the piece so if knight d5 attacks
the queen and knight
you could move the queen queen b7 and
now let's say knight captures here
you're just gonna capture here
and once the knight moves uh just uh uh
bishop to b4 with an attack a double
attack on the d6 pawn and after captures
captures
yes white didn't really achieve all that
much but white doesn't need to achieve
all that much white is up the exchange
and you're you're just winning here
black has no
uh black has no counter play you're not
you're never crossing the d5 square the
rook is pretty useless on the c
file if this bishop doesn't open up and
uh
with the queen guarding the pawn it's
never opening up so here
uh magnus said okay let's try something
different let's play d5
and uh it it does come with um
uh with some poison uh but now gurishuk
just continues with his plan
queen to a7 now attacking the bishop
attacking
the the pawn here and the bishop is now
overloaded you cannot defend
both of these squares if you try for
example queen d7
then again white just trades down white
doesn't care because white is already up
material just knight captures and after
you capture let's say bishop captures
you trade queens
captures captures and after rook
captures uh black really doesn't have
all that much
now you're you're attacking this you're
still up the exchange
and the black has no counter play
white's position is super solid here
so after this queen to a7 move uh
instead magnus decided to go for bishop
to a8
he realizes that he needs to give back
some material
uh but that he will get some counter
play at least
so here knight captures an a6 grisha
grabs the pawn
also threatening knight to c7 with a
double attack here
but magnus finds a very nice idea bishop
to f8
and here magnus allows well allow is a
strong word as there's
not not much you can do with black but
he finds a way how he can regain some
material after
all of this has been traded down so here
in knight c7
uh with a double attack and magnus now
pins it queen e7 so of course now you
cannot capture because the queen would
hang
so here knight captures on b5 ugly just
uh
you know continues merrily grabbing
those juicy pawns
uh and now queen back to e8 magnus
cannot allow to trade queens as he's
just down too much material
knight back to c7 and now queen back to
e7 again you cannot move the knight
because the queen hangs but now bishop
to b6 and now the queen is defended and
uh
knight captures bishop is coming and now
comes uh
the idea that magnus had in mind when he
played bishop to f8 he plays d
captures on e4 and okay knight captures
an a8 now the queen trade is forced if
you don't trade queens you're just down
a piece
so uh we have uh queen captures on a7
trading queens bishop captures and
rook capture 78 and now the bishop has
to move and now this bishop
on f8 move finally makes sense uh magnus
did all this to regain some points as
fighting against
three connected pass pawns would be uh
would be pretty much an instant resign
so bishop back to f2
and now bishop captures an a3 with king
c2
and bishop now goes back bishop to e7 as
magnus doesn't want to suffer
any uh rook to a1 and then you're not
going to be able to move the bishop
because the rook is on the same file so
rook to a1
of course gerishuk now wants to trade
and magnus of course declines the trade
and now if you see if if you look at the
what's happening on the board it's five
points each
uh with magnus being down the exchange
but he he does have a bishop at night so
he will of course still play rook hd one
grisha claims the only two open files on
the board with
with his rooks and now captures on f3
captures and e4 magnus wants to get his
knight and bishop into the game
so he he even does this we have captures
captures
and now as the bishop to f6 is probably
the next idea
bishop to d4 and gerishuk just stops it
and
f5 now magnus also starts pushing his
pass pawn
king b2 and the king to f7 both players
now improve the positions
of their kings and the b4 now now
gurishak starts pushing on the queen
side
and magnus of course uh returns the
fader favor by pushing on the king's
side so g5
king to b3 and now g4
uh we have rook to a7 pinning that
bishop and now of course magnus on pins
right away king to e6
rook to a6 check and king to f7 and now
c4
uh continuing to push and here magnus
could play something like
h4 uh get the g3 into to start pushing
those pawns as fast as possible
however he plays bishop to d6 first uh
going after the h2 pawn and
it kind of seems like this wins a tempo
for black because white has to react to
this
uh the truth is it loses a tempo because
agriculture plays
bishop to g1 defends and now attacks the
bishop so you haven't really won a
temple here
you have to react to this and you can't
really
do all that much i mean where are you
going to move the bishop and
the the the pawns are coming so here
magnus defends it with the king but now
comes
c5 the bishop now has to move bishop to
e5 and here gurishuk just played
rook to d5 and it was in this position
animal 46
uh that magnus carlson resigned the game
as there is really nothing more to be
done here the king cannot approach uh
to help out with the defense because the
rook is cutting off the entire sixth
rank
uh you can to defend the bishop anyhow
and
well of course after you move the bishop
you're just going to lose this pawn and
now
you really don't have any more any more
resources to fight with if
if h4 just rook f4 goes after the knight
and the pawn and
you could give one little check but then
after this you're going to lose another
pawn and
you know uh the position just uh self
deteriorates
uh so yeah that's uh the game from the
final round uh grishok
was able to tame the dragon uh in great
style if i might say
and this game had a lot of impact on the
standings of the tournament
but we're going to show at least one
more game so we're not going to
show the standings just yet so that's
the game i do hope you enjoyed it i
would like to thank ryan beck
david kimura liam gossman francois
hesland nathan and lauren lanier for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the saint
louis rapid and blitz event the the
rabbit event is actually over even
though we're not gonna show the
standings just yet and now we're
continuing with the blitz
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and uh whatever else happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your weekend